this is the ultimatum um
again just nothing happening at all last
time Ankara Doug says it was about time
that something happened now the shit's
really hit the fan watch him tap-dance
out of this one
joke's on you use that joke last up so
um yeah well well we pretty much gotten
this one again are bouncing above
Bambang sees it bong singh said it's bot
bossing bossing say oh yeah i was trying
to remember it's like all these vowels
and it's too much for me Oh what I have
to deal with this so um anyway that was
in the process of Rossum and it's
exactly that if J into chaos and uh ma
Co tries to get to accord deliver this
message from the bad guys saying if you
don't surrender they're gonna attack the
air temple that's exactly what they do
and they do yeah and most of the episode
member is pretty much just focusing on
this big ass attack of the air temple
and and is amazing it's pretty intense
um and it's a great great belt it's nice
seeing uh because before we always kind
of had a as the the Airbender a was
great but we always kind of had one of
him and with this one you're again it's
you had a few more in in Korra but not a
ton now you have like a ton of these
airbenders and it's just this really
great big battle and it's really
detailed it's really cool uh and then it
ends with most of them getting away
except for one port ensign who may or
may not be dead it's sort of you know
veers out this way days I only happen
half - yeah no and that okay that's what
pissed me off because of course big
shock every on my facebook is returned
Tuesday Tuesday well bangs there with
that but they didn't even spoiler
because it's like we don't know if he's
dead it just sort of veers off to the
side and you had to wait for the next
episode I would be surprised if he's
dead I wouldn't I'm not saying it's not
possible but it would surprise me at the
most I can see Korra getting back and
him dying like in her
or something like that like I can see
that happening at the most but it
wouldn't be like they just come in
tensed no I felt like they just can't
look at them and they never show the
body or something you know the fact that
they cut away makes me think that he's
at least not dead yet yeah I mean I mean
you may be right if they're gonna kill
him off maybe there'll be a scene where
Cora stumbles upon his you know horribly
ravaged beaten body yeah but anyway
something up like good luck cool and you
know I mean especially after showing you
know that really graphic death of the
earth Queen it's like I don't think they
got shy away from much I mean they just
had the decency not to show you yeah but
I think with this yeah I think the idea
is that they're showing that he's being
beaten really bad you know and these are
so powerful blows I think you stumbled
upon a really really good point which is
what a brilliant move to kill the earth
Queen in that episode because it really
opens up the possibility that maybe
anyone can go if you're not maybe the
main character because I was watching
the battle and I was kind of thinking
I'm like I didn't gonna kill one of
these guys like Bumi Tenzin yeah like
they were really focusing out for a
while and so yeah and it was so intense
and I'm like well they killed the earth
Queen like that was a great way you know
from a writing perspective to Ratchet it
up and be like no this shit's gonna get
real you're not gonna be a hundred
percent sure what the hell's gonna
happen
well and to have the earth Kingdom
suddenly like you know now it's chaos
unleashed you know it's like that's like
it's two major things you know right on
top of each other
uh-oh we also have the return of a fifth
other mock oh um of Liz in the zoo cause
uh uncle I came back for a brief bit yes
uh and it's great to see him even though
it's you know again different voice but
it's like
loveseat you know that was awesome I
love the seen to wear old Zuko's like
you talked to my uncle
it gets all like kind of like oh my god
yeah and it's it's very brief but again
I think though it was very poignant for
something that was really brief yeah but
but I like that meant that's always my
favorite thing about about the show air
about this and last airbender is that
there's always kind of nice balance of
the characters and even it's just for a
second it's like yeah but it makes a
difference you know it does still kind
of tug a little bit so you don't know
maybe they'll lead somewhere to we don't
know because he's sort of like cuz that
seemed in line yeah yeah I'm just like
wait actually hi I'm actually at a point
if I wanna place bets I'm gonna bet
Zucco gets maybe my guess yeah he's he's
pretty up there and then they'll have
some sort of reunion scene in the spirit
world just to tug at our heartstrings a
little more like that would be like that
would be my guess what they're gonna do
baby show off a major character but I
don't know I mean it could be Tenzin it
could be it could be nobody maybe
they'll just design that out of the
earth Queen was enough but I like your
idea if that happens like I'm gonna cry
like a bitch Oh bad Zuko would you like
some tea yeah yeah like for you he like
uh goes back to like his younger dot a
poss go forever so I like packing Anakin
Skywalker I think is like that's how
they like you know we're the most
friendly when he learned the most and
all the most shit happens I mean that we
know of I mean you think they would show
it there's no it's so so long as Zuko
spirit isn't in the shape of Hayden
Christensen we're okay yeah we're okay
um but uh yeah so again it's getting
real and transient again the only thing
that I'm kind of like yeah get like a
give just the tweaking a little bit is
um I still like you get more of the main
villain like he explains more and he
talks more Andy at first I wasn't a big
fan of just how calm he was cuz if I was
kind of boring but now I'm starting to
dig it a little found Zen in his
nihilism yeah kind of I'm starting to
dig that a little bit more now I kind of
like that he is just so because at first
I thought was so oh my
before even now it's kind of like run
the route of crazy villains I mean the
Firelord for lunch is the ultimate of
just Milano but not just that I mean
like with um uh everyone else we can
look at and just serve no they're evil
that your phone that's my phone
I'm ignoring it okay it'll be the nice
soundtrack for this because when he goes
and he goes and tries to kill korokke
bills but Anton might be dead and it
said but it's kind of Awesome you know
it just sucks okay stop we're done we're
done
ah anywho but okay so the villain very
much uh like that's growing on me that's
definitely grown on me but at the same
time it's like only now am I starting to
sort of feel a little bit of that like
what this can do you have these three
other people that again look cool they
look awesome America they're doing the
cool bending and everything for the
minions I don't want them to just be the
minions though it's like they're they
seem like they're all in the same page
they want to do the same thing this this
guy's long at the feeling if this was
one story told over three seasons like
the original advocate like remembers
then they would have more personnel
across doulas pasta that's what I'm
saying but I was told over three seasons
I think you could have been spending
some of the time developing them a
little bit more in this one um and it
would never say this well no for that
ever if that's tweaking like I said
because the main villain like I said has
I'm now starting to see what they're
trying to do with it actually there is
something legitimately creepy about just
how calm and cool he is and say no it's
just the way it's got to be you know
just I'm kind of wondering how this is
all gonna wrap up now with a fourth
season because is this gonna carry over
into season four cuz nothing really has
that much there's cut there's kind of
bits of things that carry over but
generally the villain dies at the end of
each you know what I like to say here's
what I like to see I like to see it you
know kind of left open at this season
but more even than at the end of the
second season there's gonna be a bigger
tie-in with the spirits like oK we've
been focusing on this but then they shit
with the spirits cuz they keep dropping
in every once in a while like showing
him there but it's like wait some shit
was going on that we didn't know or
something really major weather is going
to help her it's gonna make things worse
and then at the
this season they're like holy crap and
that this was going on oh my god and
that's gonna lead to this big ultra
super cool thing in season four
well I'm considering that you know
season four is probably mostly done now
I'm sure to listen to us yeah midday my
baby sister Sisson I at least does not
like just scrapped or whatever it's like
no no you get to watch it on your iPad
oh you could only do it on iPad or
whatever um but yeah no it's uh I did I
did enjoy the meme running around that
showed um the bad guy with the Bane mask
no no that's a good one too but um oh
why am i blanking of Aang's wife oh now
I forgot a name uh Katara
Thank You Katara um it was a meme that
showed Zaheer of picking out a boo me
and the other sister and like Katara
comes in all old and everything is like
you fucked with the wrong kids looks
like I would have killed to see that
just bud oh yes it's it's a good episode
it's good building up what's gonna
happen X am I mean we're building it to
the finale here I think I mean only like
taking enough risks for you yeah now I
will like to spread out but wait are any
predictions do you think tops gonna come
in at the end of all this
perhaps I don't feel that was hinted at
enough I that would be a little jar if
there is more of the dog line I'm all
about I mean I'm all about talk but I
feel like you know they could do it I
would be like that would be weird though
why just it last I can dump in like just
off we hinted at it a little in the
middle but like I thought if there's a
maybe it depends are they right it in
yeah but I mean I'm always for more talk
so if there's more focus on the dogs
because they certainly have that that
bit in the middle and that kind of
disappeared
uh if I can't see it coming back back
quickly like if there was more focus I
could see if I at the most maybe again I
could see like a quick bit at the end
like leading into season four but if not
I think they just ever come back in
season four cuz there's really no reason
to mention her still being alive that
they were gonna have her and uh uh as I
always say it's best to go out on top
yes that's chaos that is chaos house
rises up specific how does it say one
more thing okay good uh the other thing
that I've noticed is there's a lot of
bull in hate out there I like I get it
whatever like I post my avatar there's
like I'll give it a Super Bowl in fuck
that guy I'm like this is awesome
oh not that hard I should be jeez yeah
oh no there are some people they're just
like bowing to go die in a fire I bet
you see more maka hate honestly not none
not recently recently I Ryan just going
on hole in um so I mean it's clear to me
that I think Bolin is gonna be
metalbending by the end of this yeah at
just the right moment be a deus ex bol
Innoko or something and mental the other
thing though is I like that Bowman at
the right opportunity can solve a
problem like when they were trying to
steal that airship earlier and Bach was
like we're commandeering this the name
of the longer like whatever and then
Mullins is like here hold on hey the
gold is totally on level three of the
Queen's palace you should go there and
everybody takes out me so you just gotta
know how to talk to these yeah I think
seeing everyone levels out just enough
in terms of helping out everyone sir has
there a moment which I really like
so there really isn't a one that I'm
like oh why why is this character here
whatever sometimes Bolin's jokes you
know can get you know a little okay
whatever but no but here's the thing I
mean it's like I love Sokka
but some of his jokes really so check
your mom but I love some shut your mouth
but it's like come on you nobody laughs
at every single socket joke there's
always at least like a top 5 I'm
terrible Sasha shut your mom you know
I'm right motherfucker you going right I
will flip you over the railing right
over the back of a couch but to be fair
I have always colpo in soccer white it's
okay for I say no Sam hey hey hey hey
same great taste
at the couch is crystal soccer
no I sweet call Brad this is sister Sun
crystal Sokka the only brand make me
rage actually I could totally see a soda
called crystal Sokka it sounds like a
sounds like a soda name yeah so no I
don't mind Bolin I I get it it's like
you need some jokes it is still really
it is still a Nickelodeon and its feet
this is being a very adult I mean really
you're sort of watching a bunch of grown
adult look don't even run it specific
yeah I mean it's like I mean this does
not go hand in hand with their
live-action sitcoms and their
SpongeBob's and stuff so it's a I get
heavy ball introduce see the sickle and
me just wishes it would be run in
between two episodes of Spongebob just
to mess with kids so sister I'd rather
watch it is there you go tuned and then
the earth Queen gets suffocated God we
years ago pineapple under the sea
actually they ran now do you the most
funniest thing ever they run that
episode put them right after the
chilling horrifying death she collapses
and he's just like death and then they
just blurt panic and run an episode of
Spongebob great somebody do that like
make a youtube video assistant is being
Nickelodeon so just like the most
horrifying part of the avatar shows any
of them like you know a character dying
or like you know just a horrible
traumatic scene but just who lives in a
pineapple a courtesy well you've already
seen that NIEM of like whatever the
little spongebob at the bottom pointing
and laughing at something serious in
korra like her getting hit or something
but it's like a next time on Korra but
it's also like coming up next bunch Bob
so no I see that the kori you see him
laughing and like you're getting hit or
falling yourself as punches on yeah as
it should be
so yeah
bottom line spongebob has gone downhill
I guess and watching much to begin with
but I hear things lots of things just to
be about the art yes it used to be about
the sponges we're not sponge were they
any more speak for yourself